how how are you feeling about your fight
do do you think that we're winning or
losing there's good news and there's bad
news let me start with the bad news the
bad news is that we dug ourselves a hole
over the last 50 years that is very very
deep um and the amount of economic
inequality and Injustice in the United
States for example that has been
created and not everything has gotten
worse right but um certainly if you look
at economic inequality oh yeah yeah it
like like productivity and and wages
diverged starting about 50 years ago
when they went like in TOT different
direction that's right and so we have
built we dug a whole it's a it's a it's
effectively a $ 55
trillion Hole uh which is which is the
aggregate amount of money that has
flowed incrementally from the bottom 90%
of Americans to the top 1% over the last
50 years so around two and half trillion
dollar extra that flows from the bottom
90% to the top 1% today per year and
that the problem with that whole is that
you know inequality is much more than an
economic inconvenience for the people
who who aren't well treated it shreds
the reciprocity Norms that make social
cohesion and democracy possible and
that's why our politics is so screwed up
today is that it is just an objective
fact that for most of the people in the
country certainly the bottom 80 or
90% they have been exploited in a in a
in a in a really pretty terrible way for
the last 30 or 40 years and many many
many of them have lost faith in
democracy and government for reasonable
reasons right like that it's just a fact
that if you're in the if you were a med
if you think you've been screwed you
have right you are correct you have been
screwed and if you're angry at
government for letting that happen you
have an absolute right to feel that way
you are correct you got totally screwed
and the government of the United States
of
America aided and abetted that for for
better or worse it is just a fact and
people are pissed and people on the left
are pissed and people on the right are
pissed and it is an open question
whether our democracy will
survive this self-inflicted wound that's
the bad news the good news is that when
I started on this journey in
200 six
S8 which is when I first started coming
to terms with
inequality people didn't even recognize
it was a problem if you even raised it
in polite people got angry when I first
started talking about raising the
minimum wage even the people on the left
thought I had lost my mind so Andrew
here's the thing there are
9,500 professional economists in the
United States something like that when
we debuted the $15 minimum wage not one
wrote in
support not one came to our rescue not
one published a big article in the new
New York Times saying this is absolutely
the right thing to do all this
about them about it killing jobs is not
true it's just a scare tactic this is
the right thing to do Andrew when I when
I came up with that idea even the left
laning economists who populate the sort
of left uh infrastructure of activists
thought we had lost our minds right okay
if you fast forward to today the
economic cons look Barack Obama was
President for eight years inequality
Rose under Barack Obama it didn't
decline why because he was surrounded by
economists who were neoliberals he was
trapped in that neoliberal Paradigm and
and and so here's the good news is that
that consensus has almost entirely
changed today that everywhere you look
people are recognizing how badly
neoliberalism has harmed the society or
Market fundamentalism trickle down
economics or whatever you want to call
it every University is standing up
efforts to rethink capitalism I mean
everywhere you go there's another
seminar or whatever it is on reimagining
the economy rethinking
capitalism a f you know the president of
the United States went to the picket
lines for the UAW workers right
unprecedented in American history and
so the good news is that 10 years ago
even the people who should have been
fighting
for uh for the right stuff were
paralyzed uh and today they're all
engaged in the fight like look why is
the Biden Administration the most
transformational Administration on
economic policy in since Roosevelt
because they're the first Administration
since Reagan to break with neoliberal
Orthodoxy right that's a clean break
they just said we don't buy this
anymore we're going to actually
improve people's lives all this nonsense
about job is just it's just nonsense
just it's just a red herring and so
that's the good news is that we are in a
moment of transformation a lot of people
the the the E economic and political
consensus is rapidly changing and there
is real Hope For Real Change and it may
be too
late you know like and it may be too
late uh which would be uh terrible and
sad and awful for you and me and a lot
of other people uh but but so that's
that's my view is it is that there's
some bad news and some good
news hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you